- I was going hard.
I want to go to sleep every night
replying everybody and every email.
I thought it was imperative.
I didn't have a platform
other than making real relationships.
I believed in it.
I believe in it today.
It's why I'm here right this second.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] You got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
- [Gary] I just want to be happy
don't you want to be happy?
(bright upbeat music)
- So, Gary, first of all,
thank you for joining me.
And so I want to start
this off about a story
that started in 2011.
Let's see if it rings any bells.
I had a NIX blog at the
time, was writing every day
and was communicating
with you back and forth.
And I wanted to go to your book signing
for The Thank You Economy,
back in March of 2011 in New York City.
But my mom wouldn't let me go
because it was a school night.
And I text you or dm you rather,
and I said, Hey, Gary,
my mom won't let me go
to this book signing.
This is the issue I'm running into.
And you said, that's
great, what's her number?
And you called her on...
- My God, brother that's you?
- Left her voicemail.
And it is something that my
college friends I talk to
my mom, we talked about to this day.
So what compelled you
to give your time of day
to a 15 year old kid?
And what did you say to
my mom to convince her
that I should come to your book signing?
- I don't want to lie.
So I don't remember all
the details of what I said
but I actually remember the setup to this.
And I've done maybe like seven to 12 calls
in the last 10 years where
I've had enough awareness on me
that people would want such a thing.
A bunch of answers.
First of all, thanks for
having me on the show.
I mean, you are like winning
the serendipity of my,
you completely figured
out how to hack my brain
because here's another
serendipitous moment.
I also think you did a blog
post that I left a comment to
or something like that.
I saw you say on Twitter.
So you're clearly good
at getting my attention
or understanding what
pulls at my heartstrings.
I think what compels me is gratitude.
I'm grateful, like
watching people respond,
like me reading the tweets
when I decided to do your
podcast randomly the other night
and people thinking that was cool.
I'm not ever gonna be a
person who doesn't think
that that's cool.
Like I'm still the same person in my brain
that I've been before
anybody knew who I was.
So for me to think I'm
in a place in my life
where people think it's cool
that I'm doing this podcast.
That like, it's a big thing
for you for me to do this.
Now, listen, my admin team,
my leadership team's mad
that I'm doing this 30, not overall
but on December 14th,
we're closing budgets.
There's a lot going on right now.
Even I saw it this morning.
'Cause I didn't know.
I kind of thought we
would do this at night,
one night, late, late night.
And I was like, Ugh, you know
there's some real I
gotta get done, you know,
but just operational,
that's just valuing time.
That's just taking care
of your responsibilities.
It's not big timing.
I'll never be that person.
And I'm just humbled by it.
And you know what I
probably told your mom is
what I believe, which is if
I was doing this right now
for a 15 year old, I'm
like, look, in my soul
I believe the things that I talk about
and where the world's going.
And if you have a 15 year
old, that's connecting to it
that this might just actually
be a good use of time
because all the things that
you would do for homework
on a school night is very likely
not gonna be more valuable
than the people you learn
or some of the ideas
that will be put into your head at night.
And so, you know, I'm sure your
mom appreciated the effort.
I, you know, I'm stunned
by people's lack of effort
or appreciation or gratitude
towards their communities.
It's why I engage some
of the people that were
not as into me in your comments
and saying, I'm stuck here.
You know, it was really funny.
I replied to one of them
was like, I can't win.
Either I'm pushing people to
not sleep and work too hard
or I'm pushing people to be to patient
and not go about getting that money.
And I was laughing.
I'm like, it's an unwinnable game.
And I think context is everything.
But the reason I engaged
in some of those comments, Danny, is
is because I appreciate
them having opinions.
Like, you know, like I know
that nobody really knows me,
You don't, you don't really know,
you know people that
are closest to you know
and like people are making perceptions
and like the world's
crazy people make up shit.
Like man, people taking
photos with me at the airport
and then posted on LinkedIn
that we had a business meeting.
People have said not nice things about me
in public or private
because I didn't give them
money for their startup
and they just make up stuff,
like life's complicated.
And so as you start getting more notoriety
and you get more cheering and booing.
You kind of got to go into
this then place of like,
Hey I'm gonna try to do
all the best right things.
And at the end of the day,
when I'm old and I die,
more people will cheer than boo.
Because only so many people
are willing to make up shit.
And so that's kind of how I navigate.
- It's a beautiful place to be.
And from what I've seen looking at you
for the past 11 years is that same guy.
I started following your
content when I was 13 years old
and something in me saw that
this person is gratitude.
This person is looking out
for the best in people.
And it was that that attracted me to you
and to your content.
And for that, I'm really grateful.
So my question to you, my follow-up is
what do you do?
What do you go to that place
when you see all those negative comments,
what is going through your head?
How are you navigating that
into a positive, into empathy.
What's practically going on in your head?
- One, it's a blend of a couple of things.
Hey, maybe they caught something I said.
First it's accountability.
Hey, maybe I need to do a good job
explaining something on a podcast
and it turned that person off,
Hey, maybe we didn't edit an
Instagram clip well enough,
and the context was lost,
even though I write the copy
always to like set up the video.
Maybe they didn't read the copy.
Maybe I fired their best friend
and they thought I was unfair,
'cause their best friend didn't
tell them the whole picture.
Maybe, I go through those
series of things or...
And then I go into the
macro, maybe they're unhappy.
They just wanna tear somebody down today,
and I just happened to
be in the feed that day.
Maybe, maybe they took my
advice of being patient
and it was too patient and they lost
and they're like, fuck Gary B.
They don't want the accountability.
It's more fun to point the finger.
So for me, first, I focus on
pointing my thumb at myself.
What have I done to make
people misunderstand
or maybe misconstrue.
When everybody tries to
say that I talk about
overworking yourself and hustle porn.
I'm like, man, I didn't
do a good enough job
in my early career to talk about
this was contextual to the time.
You know, the economy collapsed.
People were out of jobs,
people were hurting.
The internet was exploding,
was a huge opportunity.
And even though I talked
about being happy and doing it
for 50,000 a year, if it makes
you happy, for some reason
maybe my Jersey energy,
maybe 'cause I didn't do a good enough job
clarifying along the way.
Maybe I let that word hustle
get too attached to me
and didn't quite...
I still love hustle.
It's called work ethic.
Nobody's gonna fucking do
anything without work ethic.
It's not gonna happen in a meaningful way.
But, that doesn't mean
I'm talking about burnout,
or suicide or unhappiness.
As a matter of fact, the reason
I think I talk about so much
of not doing it for the cars
and the rides and the
jewelry and the trips,
is 'cause I think that usually means
people want affirmation from
others that they've made it.
And that if you care about
other people's opinions that way
you become very vulnerable,
and I don't want that for people
'cause that's what leads unhappiness,
'cause there's always
gonna be somebody richer
more famous, prettier, bigger
car, you know what I mean?
You get into this cycle so...
By the way, the other
place I go, my friend,
I don't expect everybody to
consume 19 hours of my content
and have every T and I crossed.
There's a reason that people
that have more consumption
of my content feel better about it
because they've been able
to see a contextualize
versus somebody seeing
three viral videos ever
and deciding that's who I am.
So what goes through my mind is,
they're right because they're human being
and that's their opinion.
And I've got to do a
better job clarifying.
I didn't talk about the fact
in the first 10 years of my career,
that my dad owned Wine
Library and I didn't.
Because I felt like to be
frank, to be very transparent,
I felt like man, I really built
a huge business for my dad
and I left and I didn't
want people to be thinking
my dad was a bad guy.
I knew that a lot of
Americans don't know about
immigrant family businesses where,
I didn't want my dad to look bad
that I built something
from four to $60 million
and I got nothing.
What was me?
Oh my God.
Such is such a dick, fucking child labor.
I didn't want that.
So I overprotected him.
But then that led to people being like
don't listen to this guy
who's handed everything.
I'm like, fuck that, I'm the reverse.
I gave up the first 15 years of my career
to build something for my
dad but still someone else,
I had to start VaynerMedia
at a fucking conference room
'cause I know fucking money.
So like, you know, like,
you know, that shit.
- Something, a lot of
people don't know about you
is that you were ahead of
the game on domain names.
And I believe you owned
kanyewest.com at one point
and gave it away to him for free.
I gave it away to
somebody who at the label
we had Kanye West, I
think Kanye West was.tv.
And that's when video was blowing up.
We definitely had young,
we had rickross.com.
We had youngjoc.com.
Yeah, we had a bunch...
I was always playing.
We owned Caymus Wine and
Silver Oak and Opus One.
I did that.
All the rap stuff in 09
was just cause me A. Jay
Mike Boyd were into it and
just super hyped on it.
It was, but I did that at
96 with all the wineries.
And I didn't do it at malicion, you know
I did it out of like, you know
I'm gonna grab them
because they're an asset.
And then I, then all those
wineries and all those rappers
when they came around and asked for it
I was all about that life.
It was more all, you know.
Now I was learning.
I was trying to learn,
you know, like, yeah.
But I loved, I owned a
bunch of domain names.
You know, I owned a lot of cannabis URLs
back in the nineties because I was like
I'm gonna be in the wine business.
And in 20 years, cannabis
is gonna be legalized.
And, you know, I did a great job
and I did terrible job because
I just let them run out.
Because somewhere around year
six or seven, I was like,
ah this is never gonna happen,
sure enough it's happened.
But yeah, I've always liked
understanding consumer behavior
what humans would do
and what would be the assets in that game.
- And you gave those
away, or you sold them?
How did that...
- I gave them away.
because that was really their IP.
I was hacking, having fun
but I would never take a URL.
Even the wineries that are
businesses, I gave it to them.
Didn't even, you would feel
a little bit better maybe
with a business than with,
but it just never, it
never even crossed my mind
that was gonna take somebody else's name.
I was trying to learn.
I was trying to see if I could at the time
because, I mean, the wine
stuff, I mean, you know
people were saying the internet was a fad
so you didn't even know.
So at that point I was trying
to learn, build other things.
'Cause I didn't, I wanted to
learn how traffic was working,
how search engines work.
This was a long time ago.
With the rap stuff we were sending,
we were sending traffic
from my space to the sites
to then drive back to their
My Space and other at the time
I don't think it was, I
don't think it was Napster.
It was learning.
That was culture branding.
So, no, I didn't sell any of those.
Because I didn't think that was
the appropriate thing to do.
I think it was more about,
about learning what was
contemporary in the market
and how traffic worked around it.
So it was more like a lab for me
than like a domain squatting arbitrage.
And I'm not even sure, you know, I'm not
it was never a big game for me.
So I don't even know, like,
can you do that to humans?
Do you do that with general terms?
What the IP laws are trademarks.
It just, that's not where
I go for money-making
but is where I go for
learning how culture works.
Which is something I
spend way more time on
than I think many realize.
- You've said before that
you are going to be the most
famous person in the world.
You said that very recently.
And I'm curious, you said the reason why
is because you know what to
do with the fame and you know
to give kindness and love,
et cetera, et cetera.
But I'm curious, when did
that realization occur to you?
Oh, Oh, shit, we're onto something here.
- Couple of things, one,
I'm just thinking about
like how that statement lands.
This would go back
to like reasons why people
leave funny comments on social.
You know, I'm fascinated by
how replicatable and obvious
it is for me to build awareness
for a human or a brand.
That was the point of I'm
gonna be the, you know,
that was the context of that statement.
You know, I was 34 years old
before I decided to make any
real, 31 for Wine Library TV
and 34 for business content.
It never crossed my mind that
people would know who I was.
I always wanted to be a good businessman.
I always knew I was a marketer.
But probably about five years ago,
I was like, wait a minute.
This is real, Probably when I
rebooted Gary V aggressively,
There's the kind of 2009 to 11 version.
13 and 14, I'm pretty
quiet except for keynotes,
'cause I'm really deep in Vayner.
And then when I knew I wanted to be a...
Check this out, I'm
doing it in 2006 to 2011
Vayner Media is now rolling
and I'm focused in 13 and 14 being CEO.
But that means I stopped
really doing Gary V content.
'Cause I stopped doing
Wine Library TV in 2011?
And I didn't have a daily show.
It didn't have anything.
Somewhere around 2000 early 14.
And I'm like, wait a minute.
What made me dominant was
that I was a practitioner.
I'm doing it.
I'm now two years removed.
I don't feel super strong.
I kind of know how to
do Facebook advertises.
I kind of like, I'm good, but
I'm not the best in the world
like I was in 2010 or at
least one of them, you know
This is me talking to myself by the way.
So we do it in Gary V was a way for me to
with the Ask Gary V Show,
which was the really
the start of this all.
And then that led to Daily V
and that led to being very
serious about Instagram
and other platforms.
That was more about me
being a practitioner
than it was about...
My notoriety, fame
awareness is a by-product
of my obsession to be a practitioner.
And the only thing I
have 100000% control over
is me the human being.
More than Wine Library
more than VaynerMedia,
more than anything I'm involved in.
And that is why I am who I am
and do what I do in my life.
- You've said that you were 1% unhappy
when you started Wine Library.
I'm curious, what were
you 1% unhappy about?
- When I left, when I
started Wine Library TV.
- Yes.
- My dad and I were fighting.
- Really?
- Yeah.
My dad and I were fighting
because I built a huge business.
I was now 30, you know
that three, O, can...
Even I was talking about don't
let three, O fuck you up.
But like it's because I, even for me
I have to question myself like, Hey,
November of of 2005 is when I decided
to do Wine Library TV.
'Cause I was looking at YouTube,
I'm like, this is gonna happen.
And I was so right about
things with Google AdWords
and email and I was starting different.
I was starting to change.
I was like, I'm good at this.
I, this is different than
just being a wine retailer.
I understand communication.
And I don't even think
I said it that smartly
or use that big of a word, nothing.
Communication's a big word.
It was just like, I understand
what people are doing
or will, I think YouTube is gonna be big.
I'm gonna start a YouTube show.
But that was really on the back of my...
there's a flicker photo
that's on the internet
and it's a bowl of pasta
I ate at my desk at Wine
Library in December of 2005.
And it's a drawing a layout
of gourmetlibrary.com.
I don't say that's what it is.
But it's a drawing of gourmetlibrary.com
and a yellow bowl with some pasta sauce.
I got to find this photo,
somewhere on Flickr.
So I have like four Flickr photos.
And I basically say something like one day
people will know why this picture matters.
- Wow.
- And what the picture represented was
I was ready to do something else.
But I knew that if I
left my dad's business,
and my dad and I were fighting
because I was like
starting to feel tension
of not making a lot of money
and not owning anything
and working 15 hours a day
for eight straight years
and built a massive business for him.
And he was feeling tension
because the whole industry
looked at me as the man
because I was operating and
could care less about him.
And he didn't feel like
he was being respected.
So we were both losing,
which leads to rams butting heads.
And so I realized like we
were starting to get close
to the time where, I always kind of knew
in my back of my mind that I
would do something for myself,
potentially if, depending
on what life worked out.
So that's what was happening there.
And you know, five,
six, seven weeks later,
I filmed the first episode
of Wine Library TV.
I was gonna launch Gourmet Library.
But Wine Library TV worked
intuitively right away.
The first a hundred
episodes, nobody gave a shit,
but I was seeing it.
And I also was starting to use Twitter.
I tried to sign up for
Twitter that February
that same time I went to
a conference in London
the WiFi wiped out and I didn't
actually create my account.
So that May, so funny how life works.
I was gonna start that February.
I came back busy with other things.
Obviously wasn't a top priority.
But by that May I gotten
onto Twitter May of 07.
And between Twitter, the
work I was doing on Twitter,
driving to Wine Library TV on YouTube
and Viddler and my vlog,
which back then you embedded
your videos on a WordPress
'cause you would host
your show on your platform
not just natively on YouTube.
And it was just happening.
And I never got around to Gourmet Library.
It just, you know, Wine
Library TV took off
drove my dad's business even more.
I was learning.
I got into Web 2.0
I invested in Facebook,
Twitter and Tumblr.
I started meeting Kevin
Rose and Mark Zuckerberg
and all these, David Karp and
all these interesting people
of the early internet.
YouTube buys, YouTube sells
to Google for 1.6 billion.
I'm like, Oh my God, this is the world.
This is the future.
And I dove in head first
and a couple of years later
VaynerMedia comes out and crush it.
It is written and my career
takes a different turn.
- How, let's fast forward
a little bit to when you
start to blow up, let's
say on the internet.
How did you start to deal with the fact
that you cannot respond to everybody?
Because like I was starting to understand
when I was going through,
you blew me up from this interview.
It's like, there's so many comments.
How do you deal with the fact emotionally
such a empathetic person
wanting to help everyone.
How do you deal with the fact
that you can't respond to
everyone as at a certain point?
How do you deal with that
emotionally and mentally?
It was a tough struggle.
As you know, that was a
big platform I sat on.
Thank You Economy was about
replying to everybody.
I did it for five years.
You're still go to sleep at
four o'clock in the morning.
I would wake up at 10 and get my six,
but like I was going hard.
I wanna go to sleep every night
replying everybody and every email.
I thought it was imperative.
I didn't have a platform
other than making real relationships.
I believed in it.
I believe in it today.
It's why I'm here right this second.
You know, like, so
at some point I knew
the math was too much.
And it wasn't, for me, it
wasn't that I was burning out.
And I do think that's
what it is for others.
And if you feel like you
don't like it anymore,
you shouldn't.
But for me it was, I was
just growing too fast,
and like I'm logical.
And I was like, Oh, I can
do this for another year.
But like the math is very clear,
and maybe it's time I get to reconcile
that I can't reply to everybody.
And, but I still believe that
replying to everybody on Twitter
from May 07 to let's call it
I don't know where in 2011,
I kind of stopped doing it.
That was a weird transition to me.
It was like my norm.
I just thought, it's what I did.
But I still love responding to people
ad hoc and doing things.
And I do think what
makes social media unique
is the conversation element.
I do think that
in the 07, 08, 09 years
it was all hippie Nirvana land.
It was all nice.
It's not that anymore.
And I think that leads to
people's different
relationships with social media,
but I get great enjoyment from
engaging with communities.
And, you know, you learn things.
I reply nicely to one thing from you.
And next thing I know, I'm
like what's Money Twitter,
Money Twitter's in the building.
Like and like seeing that
whole online community.
And I always love seeing, you know, for me
I'll always be attracted
to the young bucks.
You know, when I see that
kind of energy, I'm like,
I've loved for that.
I'm like, good for that.
Like good for people like doing it.
Like, you know what I mean?
Like as a mid aged to lion now,
you know who was always a young lion.
I see a lot of mid aged
and old lions get bitter
about young lions wanting
to like shit on them,
and this and that, that
I never understand them.
I'm like you were that young lion.
It was funny.
I just have always not understood.
I cheer for the youth.
I don't understand how people don't.
I also am competitive.
You know, I was finding,
some of the comments in our
exchange, some people are like
Gary's capacity is not
about making that money.
I was laughing.
I was like, let's do a money
laugh, dick, and see who wins.
Like, you know, I'm doing
brand while people do sales.
That's where people get confused.
Nike's not out here pedaling
but that shoe is worth a zillion.
Then I think people will
evolve their thinking
and things of that nature.
But I also like the competitive spirit.
I still am in the prime of my career.
So getting down to win
with the young lions,
like, I can grind it
with the best of them.
So I'm about that life.
But I'm also about having
a well-rounded combo
because I don't think most people have
the self-esteem that I have.
And when they're dealt with adversity
that's when they go into sad places.
I also do think that people
are flexing too much
perception versus reality.
I didn't have those issues
and I wanna be responsible
with my platform to talk about all angles
because some people
can be about that money
for a year and a half,
but ended up at zero.
I know those people.
I know unlimited people that
were about that money life
for two or three years, four years
so much so that they built an
unstable, unsustainable model
and lost all the way from
never being financially sound again
all the way to the extremes
of taking their lives.
And I think good balanced
conversations matter.
And I think that demonizing
patients makes me laugh.
That's just confusion.
That doesn't mean sit on your ass.
You know, one of the kids said something
to the thing and made me tweet.
I'm like, don't confuse
patience with non-action.
I'm out here burning it every day,
but you can't expect everything
to happen in two seconds.
- How did your grandmother's negativity
impact your own positivity?
Because I think this
is an important point.
That you were able to take that negativity
and turn into positivity.
What do you think the
relationship there is?
- It's huge.
She was a big part of my life.
She was my only grandparent,
you know, and it's tough.
She's passed recently.
It's like tough to talk
about your only grandparents
that you knew maybe in a negative light.
I don't, my grandma Esther
had a very negative mother.
I knew her, my great
grandmother, and guess what
I have a funny feeling
that my great-grandmother
had a very negative mother or father.
I just didn't know them.
So this is not the call
out my grandmother.
But, you know, I watched my grandma.
My grandmother spent her
entire summers with us.
And her negativity was very, very real,
and very against my religion
and not how I saw the world.
And I saw the effects of
how that affected my dad.
My dad has a lot of variables
that I know come from
having a negative mom.
And I also, it was also in the contrast
of me having a positive mom
and a supporting system.
So it was this crazy contrast.
And I also had my natural convictions.
So by the time I was eight, nine, 10, 11
I was already like a weird dude.
I was in my zone, in my bubble.
Sounds like you, like if you
were that young into my stuff,
you would, that's different for 13.
And I was that guy.
And so she wasn't able to,
like her negativity wasn't
able to penetrate me,
but it made me very empathetic.
I think my opening answers here
to, how do I deal with hate
probably come from the
learnings of being around
someone who had negativity in their DNA.
- Your life seems to me
from an outside perspective,
a tale of two cities
where you're able to use that dichotomy.
I don't wanna hold you for too long, Gary.
And I appreciate.
- I'm gonna go over for five minutes.
So you've got six more minutes.
'Cause I'm enjoying this
'cause you're doing a good job
asking different stuff.
And I appreciate that.
That means you're putting in the work
- Of course.
And so when you...
- But yes, you made a very good point.
I'll spend a second on it.
My closeness to negativity,
cynicism and positivity
is a very huge framework to my success.
Both sides of my family had
some opposite DNA traits
on that front and my ability to observe,
I'm a great observer.
And so you can imagine that was my life.
So I observed it.
And so I have compassion,
sympathy, empathy
and understanding of both sides.
I do not think being
optimistic is delusion.
Like I don't think when
people keep it real,
they keep it real.
I think they keep it real cynical.
Like keeping it real
is not saying anything
it's just executing.
When you're just shitting on everything,
you're not keeping it real.
You're tearing down other
buildings eight out of 10 times.
Sometimes you're keeping real,
but every friend I've had
that's a big, I keep it
real is actually cynical.
And so, you know.
- Absolutely.
So final question.
When you love as many
people, as hard as you do
with as much love, how
do you deal with death?
Death is something that is,
it seems like it's gonna happen to us all.
So how do you deal with that
when you're loving more
than the average person.
When you have that, how
do you deal with death
and how do you...
Can you talk about that?
- I can, but the way
I'm gonna talk about it
is gonna be very interesting.
The closest person I've ever lost
in my life is my grandmother.
And the reality and transparent truth is
it was probably the
weakest relationship I had
in my inner circle.
I lost three of my grandparents
before I knew them.
Two before I was born.
And my parents were in
their twenties when they,
like 20, when they had me.
20, my mom was 20 and my
dad was 21 and a half.
So, 22, he'd just turned 22.
So the reality is...
Another thing people say
to me sometimes like,
Gary, I don't listen to you anymore.
You say the same stuff.
Like, mazel, I'm like, good.
I'm like, I want to talk about...
- That's what you want.
- I wanna talk about this stuff I know.
I also believe that
one of the only reasons
to kind of stay on top of me is,
I'm very good at observing the new places.
So if I'm listening to me
I'd probably be like after
a while, okay, I get it.
Oh, okay, the reason I'm
gonna check in with this dude
or kind of keep an eye on it is
because of the Tik Tok
thing and the Snapchat.
Like, he's gonna be right, and
that's gonna be good for me.
And I'm gonna stay on that boat.
And two, seven, nine times a year
that macro thing is
good to get reinforced.
No different than the reason
I call my best friend, Brandon
or my mom because sometimes
I want a little positive reinforcement.
And I go to them.
So I'm thrilled that I am
that for so many people.
So the answer is, I don't know.
The answer to your question.
Your final question is I have no clue
because I would argue the
majority of people on this
listening to this
have been through a death
that hurt them more than me.
And they have more credibility
to speak to this subject than I do.
I can tell you that there's
an incredible amount of fear
that runs through my body
of losing one of those 10,
15 closest people to me in the world.
Because I do think I'm
gonna really struggle.
Or I'm gonna surprise
myself and be very grateful
for like, I'm a very
grateful, optimistic dude.
It's gonna be an interesting tug of war
of my devastation versus my gratitude.
And until I live it, I can't speak to it
with conviction the way I speak about
all the other things I speak about.
- Wow, I really appreciate your time.
Don't wanna take up any more of it, Gary.
- Anything else,
you know, this is gonna be it.
So I figured, you know,
I'm three minutes late for
my next meeting, anyways.
Anything that you me to
get into, anything random?
- When you started Wine
Library, what were,
did you set a goal of yourself for
I'm going to record X amount of episodes.
Did you have, you were just like,
I'm gonna go and I know
it's gonna be successful?
- Yes.
And I know...
let me tell you something
else that might help.
Actually see this is
what I intuitively felt.
It was good to get one more question.
This is gonna help a ton
of youngsters, I think.
I knew that the learnings from the process
we're gonna be valuable enough
for the entire commitment to time.
I knew that I was gonna
do something innovative.
I knew I was gonna learn something.
Think about it, I was
doing YouTube, long form.
That was unheard of.
I was using social media to promote it.
That was super unheard of.
I knew that I was gonna get
bigger into the tech world.
I was front facing camera, personality.
I'd never done that in my goddamn life.
I didn't, I got a D in speech.
I didn't, I wasn't in drama.
I was barely a class clown.
This is, you know, so I
knew that I was gonna learn
a lot about myself and
things that could help me.
And then I did it as long
as I wanted to do it,
which ended up being five
years, five days a week.
In five years doing only a
Monday through Friday show,
no weekends, I did a thousand episodes.
Think about that.
That's like insane levels of consistency.
And so I am proud of that.
And I did learn a lot.
I mean, it was foundational to my career.
I think a lot of guys and
girls listening right now
overthink the ROI of their
actions in their youth.
And they don't realize the
context and the learning
are gonna be more valuable
than the financial ramifications
in that short window.
- It's exactly what I'm
doing with this podcast.
God bless you, Gary.
Thank you for your impact on my life.
I appreciate you.
Have a great one.
- Thank you, Danny.
Bye bye.
YouTube watcher, what's up, it's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you, please subscribe
because my commitment and
exploration of YouTube
is about to explode.
Stories, polls, more
content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.